hello everyone I hope you had an
excellent weekend and we can finally
return to our coverage of the 2013
candidates tournament here is a game
between team our large oval with white
pieces against the Magnus Carlsen now
there was that dramatic turn of events
in the 2013 candidates tournament in
round 12 in the previous round vastly
eventually defeated Magnus Carlsen it
was his only loss in this tournament so
far and we've seen the standings after
after the previous round so it's letting
me to kramnik in the lead with 8 points
and trailing Magnus Carlsen with 7 and a
half so definitely a difficult situation
to be in
he would definitely enjoy a win but he
needs he needs at least a draw to even
out the score with kramnik but Kramnik
has yet to play to play his game and he
faces none other than Boris Gelfand in
round 13 so let's check out some of the
photos from this round and then we can
we can check out this game here we have
a photo of Magnus Carlsen and there a
job of here all the photographer's are
basically waiting for him to look up so
they can have a nice photo of him but he
doesn't seem to be very interested in
the end all they got was was this photo
but you know better photos are awaiting
after round 14 here okay here we have a
nice photo from the opening we can see
from the board
there's the names of Indian going on
here we have also a nice photo there you
have it cousins orange orange plus water
hidden in in the Department on the left
and uh and on the left side there's a
Peter Svidler battling it out against
and Vasilyev and choke also a nice game
that we will definitely show from this
round and here we have no that's all we
have from this from this round but I do
have some force after the game so let's
see it as you all have seen it will be
an Enzo Indian so d4 sorry it was a it
was a long weekend so d4 Knight to f6 c4
e6 Knight to c3 and you already seen
there would be an Enzo Indian on the
board Queen to c2
we have d6 Knight to f3 9b d7 g3 Carlsen
castles Bishop to g2 and the e5 now we
have castles c6 rook to d1 rook to e8 so
Adi captures on e5 d captures on e5 and
a 3 now but should capture screen
captures and Queen to e7 B for expanding
on the Queen side nice to be 6 and the
Bishop to e3 now you can't really go
Bishop to b2 with some ideas of creating
a nice battery towards g7 Knight to a4
would immediately get rid of that Bishop
on b2 so Bishop to e3 Knights to g4
attacking the dark square Bishop the
Knights to d2 and we have F 5 by Carlsen
h3 Knight captures only 3 Queen captures
on e3 and e4 now it was a very
interesting position definitely you do
want to push either efore or f4 f4 was
also very interesting but after f4 after
pawn captures pawn captures the queen
will capture and give up the pawn on e2
and after Queen captures seems like a
very nice position probable for black
but there are actually a lot of a lot of
poisonous ideas for white like a 4 for
example the Queen and Knight are nicely
guarding the c4 pawn a5 will be an idea
and if Knight captures an a5 of course
you cannot capture the night with the
rug because this rook would be hanging
it doesn't really matter
after Knight to e4 it would be it would
be a very dangerous position for black
ideas like rook to d2 are coming
you can never capture and see for now
because knife to f6 would win the Queen
so not something black really wants to
do so after this Queen to e3 we have E
for rook a to c1 and Bishop to e6 now
Queen to c3
putting more protection to the c4 pawn
rook a to the 8th and Bishop to f1 now
c5 by Carlsen pawn captures in first
Knight to a4 attacking the Queen and the
c5 pawn queen before hand now Knight
captures on c5
nice the b3 attacking the pin piece and
now rook captures an b1 rook captures
and night 286 attacking the Queen and
Carlsen offers an exchange of Queens
which are Java accepts Queen captures we
have rook captures and III now and if
you look at this position it's a pretty
pretty equal ending both players have a
knight bishop in the rook the butler's
have six points but one thing you can
notice is that cousin has a slightly
better pawn structure so he has to point
islands and Roger Bob has it one two
three point islands so basically it is
an equal position but not completely
equal like it's slightly better I do to
these these small differences so King to
have seven calls and activates his King
Bishop to e2 we have b6 and rook to d8
and it's something I read somewhere that
like six out of 10 or maybe even seven
out of 10 drawn in games Carlson will
win against the very strong opponents
nice to see five offering a trade of
knights and the knight to d4 avoiding
King to f6 we have King to f1 rook to d7
offering a trade of rooks and rook to f8
to check our job of is correct and not
to trade rogues because after rook
captures and the Knight captures nice
the b5 attacking the pawn a five is
coming and but it will be it will be
harder to keep black away from from the
weak points without the rooks on the
board so I have to look to the seventh
and rook to f8 check Bishop to f7
blocking and King to u1 now we have g 6h
four across in place h6 and rook the c8
we have Bishop to e6 and now rock back
to f8 would check it's again a very very
poisonous position if you try to improve
with something like King to D to maybe
bring your King into the game you know
activate then
look after sandy for for example with
check will we knew the game will black
as now there is an a discovered attack
from the bishop to the rook and after
captures captures captures it will be it
will be a pawn up and the bishops are of
the same color so will be a winning
endgame for black
so after Bishop to e6 rook to f8 this
comes would check again Roop to f7 again
Carlson wants to exchange rooks and
again rook to h8 Roger Bob avoids rook
to c7 and now Knight the b5 attacking
the rook of course I'm sure everyone
sees that rook captures doesn't work
because simply King g7 and you've
trapped white rook so after rook to see
seven Knights the b5 attacking the rook
and the DA 7 pawn rook to d7 and knight
back to d4 so it's a very hard for
either player to make any kind of
progress here we have h5 rook back to f8
with Czech Bishop to f7 blocking and
rogue back to c8 King back to e5 rook to
e8 and now a6
rook the c8 we have looked to d6 nice
the c6 now by our job of king to f6
Knight back to d4 butter back to e6 and
now comes a rook to f8 check once again
Knight captures on e6 doesn't really do
anything because this a knight is much
better than a bishop in this position
especially this light square bishop
isn't really doing anything there and
there's really no good way to activate
it so playing this would would
definitely be torture
so after Bishop to e6 rope to f8 would
check once again King to e7 attacking
the rook rook back to 8 and now comes
Rock to d7 rook to b8 and rock the b7
now again Carlson offers a trade of
rooks and here area and this is a move
47 the players have already reached time
control a job of accepts the rook
exchange he plays rook captures better
was rook simply rock to 8 to keep
pressure on this pawn and then after
roof to c7 simply continue continue
doing what he was doing but for some
reason after Brooke - b7 he did exchange
rooks so
rook captures and Knight captures and
now King to d2 and there will be one
moment where where where you'll see why
why he might have missed this but well
either way you'll just have to see it
king 36 we're King to c3 now our job is
also able to activate his King Bishop to
f7 we have Knight to b3 King to e5 and
Bishop back to F 1 we have a5 Bishop to
e2 butcher back to e6 and butcher back
to f1 so once again the rooks are off
the board but still no progress can
really be made by either side Bishop to
d7 Bishop to e2 Bishop to a4 now
attacking the knight nice to d4 Rajah go
doesn't want to allow this trade a
bishop for a night as his Knight is much
more useful here
nice to see 5 we have king b2 bishop
goes back to e8 King to c3 Bishop to f7
Knight to c6 and the King to decide the
king 36 9th to d4 we have Knight to d7
and nice to be 5 with check King to c5
and knight back to d4 so still it's
pretty much you know back forth back and
forth back and forth really no no
progress is being made here Knight to e5
we have Knight to b3 with check King to
c6 and this is move 64 and here are a
job of should the Rajah bow should
simply go something like nice to be 2
and you know everything is protected you
know it either waited out or or do
something as as you've seen in the
standings
Raja bow is in the last place so for
place so I win in this game it doesn't
really do all that much for him I mean
yeah ok maybe one you want at least beat
Magnus Carlsen while you're playing in
the candidates but other than that
really it wouldn't really make any
difference to the standings you know for
him but ok it nevertheless here he
played a 4 and a 4 is a move that after
Carson saw he immediately started you
know playing for the win as this changes
the structure of the position
dramatically
so he played King d7 we have nice to d4
into D 6 now a knife to b5 with check
and kink to c5 and here is probably an
idea or a Java mist we have nice to d4
here and here a Java so correctly that
Bishop captures on c4 is impossible
there's no way for you to win upon this
way because after Bishop captures Knight
captures you have nice to e6 check King
to d5 and Mountain Knight to f4 check
and you have to go back as you have to
protect the knight on c4 and after you
do go back then comes Knight captures on
g6 the material is once again equal but
you've eliminated the base of this pawn
chain and it will be a much better and
easier to play position for white but
after this knife the d4 move he might
have missed a bishop to eat by Carlsen
now Carlson goes 40 for the weak
a4 pawn so we have nice to be three
which is which is the best move and it
it's very nice
rajamma found this idea defending with
Bishop to d2 is of course not possible
then if you move the bishop denied will
capture and c4 without problem
so Knight to b3 with check we have King
to d6 and now comes c5 so this was a
reserve of Syria we have King King to c7
or you can simply capture it and a white
will capture on a5 so King c7 we have
King to d4 and now Knight to c6 check
King back to c3 Knight to e7 seek after
some b6 with check King b6 and now
Knight to d2 Bishop captures on a4 there
I mean there there is no way to defend
the pawn so nice to d2 is the best move
but captures on a four-night c4 with
check and that this was also a very nice
idea has now if you want to of course
and wants to keep protecting the a 5
point he has to go either to be 5 or to
a6 which is on this bishops diagonal but
luckily for him after King to a6 there
are no deadly discoveries here for white
so we have night to a3 check King to b7
and now Knight back to c4 King back to a
sex by Carlsen night
to a 3 and now if Carson repeats then
it's a draw by threefold repetition but
cousin plays King to a seven of course
he is now up upon he doesn't really want
to draw and he does have to catch up to
Vladimir Kramnik so King to d4 Knight to
c6 this comes with check king c5 and
Knight to e5 now we have Knight to c4
offering a trade of knights 90 to d3
this is with Chuck and King D for of
course if you capture captures captures
then this will be a very dangerous pawn
you don't no longer have time to capture
the a5 pawn and after you go go for the
pond and worship c2 will defend it and
then you constantly have to worry about
two threats and here it would be
impossible for white to defend so after
93 King before we have nice to see one
attacking the bishop bishop f1 and now a
beautiful move by Carlsen
it's Bishop to b5 attacking that night
and of course the knight is now unable
to move because Bishop captures on f1
would win the game so Knight captures on
a5 there's really nothing for you to do
here if you don't do anything
black will just push the pawn and win
the game so here our job of thought I'll
go Knight captures an a5 I will give up
a piece but I will grab two points so
Bishop captures on f1 we have Knight to
c6
this comes with check King b5 and now
Knight to e7 going for the g6 pawn
Knight to d3
we got Knight captures on g6 and king -
king to c7 by Carlsen so white is now up
a pawn but down a piece sometimes this
will you know be enough but
unfortunately for the job of not in this
game nice to e7
we have Bishop to h3 now Knight to d5
would check King d6 and nice to f6 now
across and captures on f2 of course
Rajah bow will capture here on h5 so
first cousin simply played Bishop to g4
and it was in this position that Tim our
job of resigned the game so I win that
definitely Carson wasn't planning or was
probably even hoping to win this game
from that position 30 40 50
moves ago so I mean something you're
down in a tournament it's the the
penultimate round and you gain you get
you get pretty much well some would say
a free win but it's not really a free
win I mean across and just defeated a
job of in a completely equal endgame and
it it's I mean you know in some moments
our job was even considered to be better
so the acquires and achievement and it's
something that you know it's often said
six or maybe seven out of ten drawn end
games Carson will win against very
strong opponents and you know such such
was the case here once again he squeezed
the water out of stone and we do have a
couple of more photos I prepared this
one
it's a photo after this game you can see
he's extremely happy he really can't
believe he just won this game and here
also another photo you can see that you
know that that this is the happiest
photo we have of course and so far from
this tournament and you know a several
job of behind him so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed that and I did prepare one more
photo
it's a photo from my weekend in Bosnia
here you can see that's me in front were
you know doing some rafting it's the
first time I've ever tried it and you
know if you ever have a chance to go you
know do go it's it's quite excellent and
Kent I mean I'm really really hoping
I'll be able to do it again pretty soon
as it's very very intense so yeah I
would like to thank Jamil Co Han Danny
McCullough James Morrison Michael cam
wrath and the Marco Feist for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with another game from around
13 at least one more game and then we're
gonna show the standings and discuss the
tournament a bit before the final round
but I will also be covering the Norway
championship as that begins today okay
today it's it's the classical part it's
Costin versus Caruana today and
you've all seen that Wesley so has won
the rapid event but I will put you know
some useful links in the description
below as usual so feel free to check it
out so I think I'll and I will see you
soon